Where do you see yourself in 5 years?
In Florida.
In Florida?
If you were an animal, which one would you be?
Puppy.
Ooh, why, why do you say a puppy?
I love dogs.
Now, I'm allergic to them.
You are allergic?
I'm allergic to cats and dogs,...
...pecans, walnuts, peanuts and seasonal allergies.
Are you allergic to hard work?
No.
I wanted to know: how many golf balls can you fit on a jet?
Very specific and I like it.
What would your management style be?
I'm the boss.
Yeah.
I would make them work a lot.
Are you willing to relocate?
Yeah, I'm kinda thinking about it.
Are you looking for equity?
A lot.
A lot?
Yeah.
Like percentage-wise, what are you thinking?
What would you like your salary to be?
600 to 1000.
600 to 1000 dollars?
A year, yeah.
Great.
Do you have any questions for me?
What is your salary for your job?
I'll answer that one for you because it could be more, it could be more.